good afternoon well I am apparently
miked for those of you who don't know me
my name is Michael Bernstein I'm an
assistant professor here in the computer
science department in the human-computer
interaction group and on behalf of the
human-computer interaction group and the
larger interaction design community on
campus we're very excited to welcome you
to the seminar on people computers and
design for the 2017-2018 school year so
many of you are old had it this many of
you are new I'm gonna do just a couple
minutes of housekeeping an explanation
of what this is and then we're gonna
actually get started with our exciting
speakers today so this is a seminar
series which means that it consists of
speakers who are not the faculty we
invite some of the brightest minds and
interaction people computers technology
design to the seminar which we want
which we run weekly in this slot Fridays
all three quarters of the academic year
and you are it is always open open to
the community open to students open to
the public so please join us whenever
you're interested in it the seminar has
been running nigh on I think 30 years at
this point so really really impressive
history of major accomplishments
happening here as your MC I will
essentially be introducing each week's
speaker some of you are enrolled in a
course CS 547 in order to get a unit of
credit for attending this this lecture
series if you are doing so the rules are
pretty simple come to the talks that's
basically the entire syllabus so there's
a lot more detail at CS 547 stanford.edu
basically what you need to do is each
week go to the website there's a link to
a Google forum where you where you log
your attendance
you can check through that site what
what we have a record of Gaza who's the
CA for the course has whipped that up
very kindly at the end of the quarter we
will just essentially check that you've
attended all of the lectures so you need
to attend eight of the ten in person you
can watch to remotely unless you're in a
CPD student in which
because your SCPD you should probably be
watching them all remotely that's
basically all that we need to check up
on most of the details as I said are on
this website are there any questions at
a high level about how the the course
works or the seminar series works before
we dive in okay that was easy so yes one
unit register your attendance and you're
good please we intend this to be an
interactive seminar so please be be be
the interactive part ask questions
discussed debate you know these folks
are here to share their visions with us
but also looking to learn from us in
conversation with us so I will jump in
so this week we are extremely excited to
welcome
I believe all four members of the llv
our community but two in particular are
speaking Evelyn Eastland and by heart so
Evelyn I believe has an MFA and is a
faculty member at RISD which you may
know is essentially one of the top
design and art schools in anywhere uh
and she was telling us at lunch that she
has a fascinating background that
started out working on really software
based systems and then decided to go get
some real depth on the art side of the
equation and now really brings them
together by has I believe she described
herself as a mathematician and
philosopher is what I got and has has
done a lot of work at the sort of the
intersection or the Union or I'm not
even sure what I would describe it
somewhere in the general vicinity of
many different topics that that think
about communicating abstract concepts to
large publics she's very interested in
understand getting to the core of a
complex idea and helping other people
understand that which is something that
I that I really really resonate with and
respect quite a lot because it's a very
difficult skill why if you go go search
for her name has all sorts of really
really fascinating and fun videos that I
were explaining all sorts of concepts
got all sorts of YouTube views she's
kind of a big deal
so as Evelyn were excited to
welcome both of them to stand for today
we're gonna be talking a lot about the
the year of the body and where they're
thinking about augmented reality and
virtual reality so over to you
hi I'm by heart and I'll just give a
quick intro while Evelyn gets miked up
so we are a part of LOV R we're a
research group that does virtual
augmented reality or xrm R whatever you
want to call it trying to get it with
the future of embodied knowledge is an
embodied computing when we can finally
capture the knowledge that includes the
things our bodies know things that often
get called intuition and then the other
two members of our team are also also
here Evelyn
Andrea and andrew huxley and mi Fleur
and so all four of us will be around
later
and so first because this is a class can
I just get a show of hands for how many
people are student lots of students all
right can we get hand for for non
students how many people are both
students and non-students yes
intersections okay cool and cuz this is
a class and we have so many people who
are students here feel free to raise
your hand and ask questions and be you
know participatory welcome to your first
week back at school and yeah let's let's
intro ourselves so that's us that's me I
do some stuff on the internet sometimes
that's what most people recognize me
from and then other internet works that
our research group has done in the past
four years including things like
parallel the polygons and all right
Evelyn are you miked up and ready and as
Michael said my background is in
computer science and programming
language design and then I made the
switch over to the fine arts and this is
a piece I made kind of in the middle of
that journey where this is an artwork a
triptych where the top screens are all
those are computer screens and the
bottoms are paintings and I match them
in color so this just kind of represents
where my career has gone all right
so quick intro to stuff our research
group has done we've been working
together for almost four years now and
we've really gone through a lot of topic
changes since then since VR and AR has
changed so much in the past four years
so recently we we had a 360 video in the
New York Times I guess earlier this
month showing hyperbolic space in VR so
virtual reality computers they don't
know what space is like they don't know
anything about reality so if we
programmed them to do hyperbolic space
instead of Euclidean space the computer
has no problem with that it takes a
little bit of you know four-dimensional
projections and stuff but you can do it
so that's part of our more recent work
hyperbolic stuff which was also covered
by nature see we have cred but we
started with 360 film and camera and
trying to understand how 360 3d video
would even work mathematically so that
was kind of our start was in film kind
of coming from my YouTube and film
background so those are some of our
earlier cameras that I made with like
hot glue and foam core and managed to
stitch together all the footage and then
we started to transition into 3d stuff
so both the video spherical video and
then these 3d animated characters this
is running on the web and web VR with
both 3d and vertical video components
then we started to get more 3d and
spatial this is like a puzzle game where
you you kind of move through the world
by crouching and standing on moving
platforms we added more senses to the
mix this is a multi-sensory peering
experience where you eat a peach earring
while looking at a virtual world where
you're surrounded by PT rings so and
also going back and forth between
physical objects the physical world and
the virtual world to really understand
the strengths of each and always
remember that even when you have a
headset on you're still a person
you're still in reality you still have a
body and so it's not just about your
eyes and what you're seeing but what
you're doing matters and we're we have
all these intuitions about what happens
when we walk forward we should move
forward in space we learned that you
know when I move this thing happens
where I see things a particular
different way as as I see kind of the 3d
real-world graphics this in this case
it's four-dimensional its arrangement of
monkeys that started as a physical
sculpture done with Henri sagermann and
will sagermann
and then we brought that once the
technology was far enough along into
virtual reality so yeah this was several
years ago and now we're moving more and
more towards the back and forth between
physical reality and headsets to try and
bring together what we can understand
using both so this going back and forth
has been interesting for me in the arts
like I mentioned first I started in
computer science moved to the fine arts
and physical materials at the time I
think I made the transition because
there was something missing from the way
I was interacting with the computer in
the things I could make and digest or
consume with a computer there was
something in my body that just wasn't
sitting right there was some unresolved
stuff I didn't understand there was a
lot of pain there was a lot of pent up
stuff in my body that I knew I needed to
work with in a more embodied way and I
think that's why I initially made the
the transition over to the fine arts and
left the screen for a while but then
that had its own challenges to where it
turns out if you want to be a fine
artist and you want to be making imagery
the way painters do there's a little bit
of imagination involved you do have to
kind of go back into your brain into
your mind into your past and think about
what kind of imagery you want to work
with I was having trouble doing that
then there was no amount of sketching a
no amount of looking at other artists
that was really helping me get there
until I went to an artist residency
earliest year earlier this year at the
Banff Centre for arts and creativity I
think it's called in Canada and I got
this desire of this kind of drive to
bake some cakes I had to bake these
cakes so I baked these cakes but I
didn't frost or anything they needed to
be raw they needed to be kind of messy
and then I wanted to work with them but
they were really crumbly I couldn't I
wanted to kind of rearrange them and do
things with them but they were really
frail because there were actual cakes
and we're starting to dry and crumble so
I took a 3d scan that's when the first
time kind of the digital started coming
back to me it came back to me and it
started helping me on my journey
so I did a 3d scan of the cakes and once
I had that 3d scan I could start playing
around with with the cakes a little more
like I wanted to I just with my cell
phone I made a little app and I got a
little marker and the marker if the
camera on the cell phone looked at the
marker it wouldn't make that stack of
cakes appear and so it meant I was
really mobile really easy I could just
go walk around in the world and put the
marker down look through my cell phone
and there was my my cakes in this case I
think they come from some flash back
some memories so I felt like I was
taking my memories with me to different
places and putting them out there so
like the carpet and doing things that
maybe aren't physically possible you
know on this like edge of a plant or
something and all of a sudden I had
imagery you know I was trying to be a
painter I was trying to be a fine artist
and the digital kind of started giving
me this this power again where I could
make imagery and these pictures I
started this is a quick recent
experiment where I took one of these
pictures and made a print on some fine
art paper which is why you see that
texture and I'm starting to double the
images on a larger piece of paper to see
and do think about topics of flashbacks
and the way that they come over and over
and over again just see how that feels
um another image from my flashbacks is
this drumstick ice cream that I also 3d
scanned and then put on a marker to
which I hid here under white and I just
want to see what it would feel like to
make still lifes with with the ice cream
and so here are some vegetables and
these are real vegetables and real fruit
but a digital ice cream and again this
is just in my cell phone a quick
experiment one day just seeing what it
feels like and then I come up with some
photos and these haven't made it back
out into the real world yet but maybe
I'd turn these into prints or paintings
not sure but yeah working this way just
kind of the imagery just started coming
which was really nice yeah so one one of
the most immediate compelling things
people often do in virtual reality often
like the first demo people do or try
will be a simple painting app because it
feels very intuitive to people when they
can move and then see this amazing trace
of how their hand is moving and there's
something very magical
about that actually can I get a show of
hands who has done VR of some sort or
worn a VR headset okay this is great
wow that is more people than I've ever
seen in the audience okay that's awesome
who has tried a painting app or
something like tilt brush okay oh this
is so cool
okay this is wonderful I'm so happy to
have an audience were like so many of
you know what I'm talking about like the
magic of of just having your body's
motion be captured in space and like
it's so easy to just like doodle and
draw and I love doodling I didn't think
that the work in VR would start to come
back to the magic of doodling and and
just the way that your body can kind of
just do these things and maybe you can
just kind of get into it and you're not
even necessarily as thinking about it
and the way we're used to thinking but
yeah getting that body knowledge back in
there okay so once we got hand
controller is working with spatial stuff
and I guess this is like two years ago
we you know made a quick kind of
painting drawing app and this is when we
started to really understand how
profound it is that virtual reality can
capture the movements of the body and
that's it's not about what you see and
what if you know that's the fun part
that you can see this other world but
the fact that now computation can
capture your body that's really what was
exciting to us so this is I guess a
cover of seymour papert's Mindstorms or
one of the additions of Mindstorms and
that's a turtle computer that can be
programmed in logo can I get a show of
hands who's who's familiar with logo and
turtles and stuff oh you're the best
alright so we'll just give a quick intro
that logo is a language that basically
you can program this line-drawing robot
kind of from its own perspective and in
Mindstorms it's very much emphasized
that children can find this intuitive to
learn how to program because they can
kind of embody the turtle that you can
walk forward a certain number of steps
and then turn right and see this from
the kind of perspective of the program
and trying to get your brain in the
space of seeing
seeing programming from the perspective
of the program itself is it's actually
really useful tool and I think we fit to
use more of that in programming so we
were starting to get towards these
embodied metaphor stuffs and then Alan
Kay came by and he's like you know let
me tell you about this thing we did back
in small talk and squeak with teaching
children how to program we're back in
the when was this do you remember 70s
some somewhere in the 70s where to get
children to understand acceleration how
you might program acceleration in a
video game he took it out into the real
world
here he is drying dropping a ball off of
a roof of a school and as it falls
they're filming it and so they see it
fall how does it look like it's falling
I don't know let's look at the video
frames and through the video frames we
can kind of get this visualization of
acceleration because the video frame
happens at an even amount of time but
the ball does not move linearly and then
they would take this back into a program
like measure this get real-world
acceleration out of this so he was
telling me about this and trying to like
push me towards education stuff and this
is this is an example of a squeak
program that uses this eToys
squeaky toys program that uses kind of
acceleration gotten from that experiment
and and I thought well with VR we can do
that in real time now you don't have to
drop and film and look at some frames
later once you print them out we can
drop an object track it in the real
world and get those frames to just
appear in front of us of where it's been
at every moment and then we can measure
that in real time we can get a graph of
that in real time and what I expected
was to kind of get a copy of that
experiment but in real time with the
frames in front of us and maybe we can
even program with our hands in front of
us
but what I actually learned once I once
I kind of quickly prototype this system
and I'm just going to kind of play so I
wanted to show just turn out and you
turn out
sound we can turn off the sound so when
I got in the system and started playing
with it what I realize is it's really
not about the VR part what is what's so
magical about this is that when I move
my body I know where I know what I'm
doing and then I can see an abstraction
a graph of this in this case just the
the Y position I can get an abstraction
of that that I don't have to connect to
something else I need to look at its
intuitive to me when I can feel it and
connect what I already know to what I'm
seeing instead of having to like
synthesize two different things like a
video of a thing and graph abstraction
of the thing so here yeah we have
acceleration graphs speed graphs and
then you can kind of match up the
derivatives at some point we'll see you
know like how do you get things to be
fast you'd think a thing moves fast if
you shake it really fast and then when
you see the graph you realize actually
it's not moving at all at either end of
your shake and then you can move your
arm in circles and this experience
really made me realize everything I had
been thinking about VR was kind of not
on the right track it was all about this
knowledge we have about where our bodies
are that's just instant and intuitive
okay so yes probably if you had no
display on it just trackers equally but
certainly partly this is was a big
moment for me of like the headset is not
everything it's not really about the
headset it's about this spatially track
stuff and now even without the headset
yeah you could do a compelling thing
where you're moving your body and forget
about the headset so partly okay so that
was that so I started taking like the
art body side more seriously and was
learning from Evelyn like what our
artistic practices including this idea
of making 50 of something which was an
art prompt from Vlada and I remember
early on in art school the the kind of
prompts for trying to get students to
think out of the box which is one of the
really hard things with with new new art
students it's just you know how to get
past kind of the obvious or the first
thing and so a lot of our teachers will
kind of just try to exhaust the students
you know until you're basically drop
dead and so you know they'll say like
they won't say like to draw the bowl of
fruit they'll say draw the bowl of fruit
25 times right so that by the like by
the in the first five you draw what you
see in the next five you might draw
something else and then by the fifteenth
you're just drawing something and that's
when the real juices flow and something
I shared that with the team yeah and
that's a great tool that I had never
learned was a thing and so first mi
flair I started doing this with oh I'm
gonna make 50 beds in VR it's really
quick in real time making them in a VR
kind of sketching tool making all these
beds and I'm looking at this and as the
beds got more and more kind of out of
the normal space of what you think of as
a bed and like oh I want to do this but
with embodied knowledge and conceptual
understanding and so if I can I don't
know how to make a video stop and go to
the next one but I'm gonna slowly learn
I'm gonna go to a next slide okay so I
decided to do this with the idea of
container schema so a container schema
and eventually I'll learn how to make
that volume go down yeah it's coming out
the HDMI so a container schema is the
idea of in and out and it's supposed to
be this basic metaphor that we learn as
children that there are insides and
there are upsides there's this kind of
black and white categorical boundary and
the theory by Luke Hofmann Johnson that
we were reading about in philosophy of
the flesh which has been a very
influential book to us is that we learn
this idea of in and out that we then
apply two categories to mathematics to
logical thinking to computer science
what you know is and isn't from
experience walking in and out of rooms
putting things in and out of boxes in
and out of draw
and that these bodies at these
boundaries that don't necessarily exist
because you know it's all just molecules
in space like the water bottle example
where what's the difference between the
water bottle on the table I don't know
on an atomic you know space level you
might not be able to really tell but
when we interact with it we know that
this moves and this doesn't the water
comes with the bottle and it's on the
inside of the bottle it only comes out
if we open the container even though of
course on a atomic level you know all
this stuff is moving back and forth and
there's no firm boundaries that exists
but functionally with our bodies those
boundaries exist we use them we
experience them so yeah I just made
fifty container schema just the idea
that you put a thing in a container and
now it's different now it's in its
scripted very easily and quickly in this
program too you know it turns blue and
it's in it turns our sorry out it turns
red when it's in and just over and over
and over all these container schema just
to try and get at it through embodied
movements and actions in lots of ways so
I eventually will learn how to stop a
video without and so after just
containers a light wanted to look at
sorry just what time it is okay so we we
had gone from containers to Venn
diagrams so because that's kind of the
container schema reminded me of Venn
diagrams what if you have overlapping
categories what if you can overlap
objects in the virtual world that you
can't in real life make these intersect
everything is separate and different but
in in virtual world if you want to you
can make things able to intersect
however you want and so I this giant
Venn diagram house but I'm gonna which
we actually just showed at the
Exploratorium last night we had lots of
Venn diagram stuff that was both real
with people putting them in different
categories and also virtual but yeah so
this is the the what the virtual kind of
container schema Venn diagram thing was
programmed in and Evelyn can talk about
where about that a lot of those embodied
virtual experiments have I was just
explaining with both the container
schema and then I'm briefly showing the
Venn diagram stuff was done in this
really cool framework that we end up
discovering called any land it's a
little bit like Minecraft if you haven't
heard of any land you go in you just
kind of make your world um it's really
powerful we've ended up doing a lot of
our prototyping in there so all of those
prototypes by just showed they made in
there mostly em and by and Andrea are
making a lot of them I was kind of on
the sidelines watching and eventually
anyway and actually lets you program a
little bit within it for UCS majors
there's a some scripting in there it's a
virtual world but when you scraped it
looks something like this kind of like
more like conventional no programming it
was like two fingers and a keyboard in
some words right really you're in the 3d
space and I think eventually by and
after doing a lot of programming like
this in there in any land they started
just kind of seeing the disconnect
they're like wait what we're in this 3d
world why are we programming like this
uh and I heard that question and it
spoke to me actually because I am my
background I actually worked on the
scratch project which is a programming
language for children I was one of the
lead developers on the first version of
it for seven years and also a designer
and also an educator with it spent a lot
of time thinking about what it means to
make programming slightly more embodied
that's not really embodied right but
there's a little bit there that's a
little Tac Toe colorful a little less
about just concepts has word numbers but
also conscious of concepts as shapes and
a little bit spacial for those I don't
know scratch just briefly this is a
scratch interface it is in 2d it's not
3d you get a little bit of a 2d world
this is like where you all your output
goes this is your cast of characters
this is your instructions that you can
choose from and over here you write your
code this is what the code looks like
and again you know this is what maybe
one small script in scratch looks like
and this is a an event trigger that says
when I receive start the game
do these things they're color-coded the
variable stuff is on orange and
numerical methods are in green things
like this we were trying to get rid of
syntax problems that you know might not
be so interesting to the actual code you
know why am I worried about a semicolon
that's not the thing um this was geared
towards preteens which is where like the
bright colors came from but really it's
kind of some powerful things about you
know having a repeat actually be this
physical not physical but sort of this
visual thing that just goes around code
that's inside of it so a little bit of
that little just making making
programming the way it already worked
imperative instruction you know serial
set of instructions but making just
slightly more visual so you might be
able to edit glance get what a program
does I mean that's not new visual
programs programming languages have been
around for a bit for like 50 years or so
and in addition to the imperative ones
where you take instructions that are
going in order and maybe give them some
colors and shapes there's also data for
programming which is another kind of big
group of visual programming languages
and this is an interface from I'm 3d
modeling a software that architects use
called rhino and if you want to pro if
you want to script if you want to be
putting all these boxes down you and one
is like somehow scripted you can script
it in Python Python is not visual so
somebody made something called
grasshopper which is a dataflow
interface for programming right no
shapes such as data for programming it's
kind of these a lot of wires it's
somewhat physical you kind of get a
sense that data coming from here will go
into there something will happen to
it'll go into there and so on and so
forth so a lot of visual languages it
turns out visual programming languages
um sort of fall into one of the two
categories that this blog post out there
that has a huge list of all the visual
programming languages out there someone
that's very meticulously keeping an
updated list some like the past three
years it's great and I showed it to em
and by because I wanted them to see that
many of those languages from that long
list including the one they were using
themselves in anyway and did really fall
into just one of those two categories
you know it's supposed to be visual
languages that are doing something novel
but really they were either all like
this just kind of like taking
serial information and putting pink box
around it
and a lot of that those ideas actually
did come from the same squeak that that
squeaky toys have I showed earlier from
LNK in the 70s or their data faux I mean
they're like you can barely tell them
apart I don't know and I don't know what
all these systems are but it's just you
go down the list and they look one of
the one of the two ways that's it except
for one one exception being the actual
oldest one in the list from 1963 by mrs.
sketchpad this is the programming system
called sketch pad by i've been several
women in 1963 and this one Stan stands
out for me and among the rest of them
because it's actually all you don't see
the numbers you don't see the words you
just see the thing and you actually see
a hand and it's direct there's something
there the body is involved and there's a
direct manipulation of what you're
trying to program this is a constraint
system so there is something more than
just drawing this is not illustrator
they're actually setting up constraints
but the computer can use later to to
constrain sides and and these drawings
so it's an actual programming system and
I thought yeah this is kind of this is
kind of the direction a by and I'm
started saying well you know we're in
any land we're in this virtual world if
we program it why don't we just program
it in 3d
why don't we program it with our hands
with our bodies it just makes sense and
I I don't know I think I just served as
advisor and I was like yeah I just do it
and that's all I said and then when when
you get enough of this like history of
how things have been and how people
think about stuff and just to realize
that a lot of the things and ideas about
computing and what computers could be
and should be that existed in the 50 60
70s a lot of those really haven't come
to fruition and some of those ideas have
been iterated on many times and it just
made us think how do we move forward how
do we get out of these ways of thinking
and do things in a new way and like why
are we so stuck is it a conceptual
problem or is it that it's just hard to
implement and so we wanted to start
prototyping some things so this is I'm
gonna play play a video of some of our
first sketches into
you just first was to kind of directly
copy some of these older languages into
virtual reality so this is a logo turtle
that it's programmed to you know move
forward ten steps and then turn who
knows what number of degrees that is
some number of degrees which is which is
right here program inside the turtle so
we wake up we put down our pen and then
five times we repeat this 144 degrees to
the left and so that's kind of the first
most obvious thing like what if we had
programming blocks and that we can move
in space and we have our library of
turtles and we can have them and put
them together this this says by the
program looks like it writes my name via
and it looks like what it does so that's
kind of fun although that can be harder
with iterative things so this was like
kind of the first step we were like okay
all we're gonna do is take these
programming blocks and manipulate them
with our hands and not the real world
but it is the real world VR is part of
the real world I think so we interact
with it in this way and and can program
so but that to us is like the very first
step
kind of boring we just copied it and try
to make it a little more interactive but
still kind of based on that paradigm and
I'm gonna skip ahead again so this is
life-size now right now we can like walk
around on our programs and kind of go
along the arrows and the lines sometimes
maybe if we have our turtle that has a
loop programmed inside it maybe we can
like embody the loop and walk around and
kind of follow the steps of the program
instead of like looking at the page and
going down the screen you can have it in
life-size around you and that's very
easy to prototype in VR you just make it
bigger instantly so I'm gonna move yes
[Music]
yes programs - yeah if you have any land
and visiting any land is is free if you
have a vibe we have a lot of public
world that have programming bits
including our programming Public Library
so we we can program these behaviors
using these programming blocks this is
design fiction where you know secretly
we have to program it in the old any
land way with these words but we're
pretending we're programming it with
this little bit of code that says when
touched emit bird and then when you
touch it a bird comes out and it should
be that easy that oh I have my one touch
action I add my kind of omit that quotes
a bird in the hands and then I can just
attach that to anything it's a little
little chunk of code that's connected to
the real world that it's programming and
we realized that you know the kind of
copy of scratch version would have the
programming blocks be on top of each
other in order very like a med like
following the metaphor of the page and
the metaphor of the written word on the
page is kind of what all computing has
been based on for a long time and
screens and tablets and then we realize
we could get really sculptural with it
we can arrange in space different ways
and make it like this chunk able thing
in your mind where you look at it and
you know what the code does because you
wrote it and it's in this sculpture and
now it's a single conceptual thing
instead of a collection of parts and
then you can go inside and play with it
so those are some of those experiments
and some where I will be able to
actually advance the slide or I will
just have to do it this way again
someday
someone will teach me how to do this and
this is so this is like a collision
library except it's a forest and I can
walk through these branching if
statements that say stuff about
collision you know we're looking at the
distance between body and an object and
then we're trying to do a collision
detection algorithm ultimately to get to
these two different behaviors
when near door when walked into and it
aside whether we're just me or something
or actually walking into it this is kind
of the the collision algorithm going on
and all of these trees are different
branching if-statement trees that decide
the collision and so I can kind of take
that whole collision code and plop it
into whatever I want and because I can
see it's this little forest inside of my
other code like I know what the forest
is even even if I can't see all the the
detail so this idea of how to get a
high-level understanding of a concept
without having to read every line so
yeah those are the Turtles you saw so we
started trying to get out of just the
directly translating thing and just get
more towards different more embodied and
physical ideas so here we're calling a
function the function is called dog and
we're calling regarding frog so we call
and we're asking about frog and you know
what it opens up its arms we can see
what the function does and then it can
he'll get function back in then we just
want to use it and this is a Fibonacci
I'm kind of generator where you know
it's iterative it calls itself and we
kind of have this animation of how that
works but that doesn't work right now
here is a sketch of programming neural
nets where we kind of have these inputs
and you can just connect together the
things in your body and with with your
body and see in each neuron kind of the
thing is optimizing for and how those
connect together and of course when you
import a library you should be able to
just import a library and the library
should look like a library and it comes
in on this library barge and this code
library in fact if you go inside and
this is public also on any land it has
you know these are the different kind of
events you can trigger and then we've
got different actions and some like
special tools like importing or stuff
like that and so yeah you walk into this
library there should be a help desk
where you can talk to someone and they
can help you and everything should be
documented and spatial and because
understanding libraries is tricky
sometimes you want to just be able to go
into your library understand what you're
getting
and also what you're ruining because
that can happen sometimes so this is
this is our library concept and then
Evelyn took that because Evelyn is
brilliant it's like yeah I just kind of
put the library in a library like AR I
really wanted to see what it would feel
like to have this programming language
value and we're designing MVR out in the
world with real objects too so the first
thing I did was again those markers like
I was doing with the cakes but this time
with just the sum of the primitives from
the language and I was in a library one
day put them in there took a picture you
know going to a library I want this
function today um kitchen table
you know it's bring them into my house
this is just to show that they really
are kind of just these mirages on my
table but to me they're also programming
blocks sliding I just wrote like two
tiny programs you know with my objects
in my house I just want to see what that
would feel like to have it be like play
Iron Man for a minute I earn woman um
and you know yeah when when dinner is
ready wait if dinner is ready then say
dinner's ready yes if the onion is hot
[Laughter]
yeah things into the real world and
seeing how they feel it's kind of a
process I've been learning how to bring
into my practice of understanding VR and
just said like pretending to program and
kind of we call it human compiled
programs when we take these blocks and
we're writing out programs and there's
no compiler but we we know how they're
supposed to run and bugs don't exist
because we're designing the language so
it needs to do what we think it should
do because we're kind of designing it
and so we work in VR that sometimes is
what it looks like when we work in VR
and also here this is our or one of the
versions of our virtual office and we
always want to remember what is what is
in the real world so even though I'm
looking and like kind of interacting
with virtual objects I'm also still in
the real world and so we've been trying
to get the real world to be a place
where we can program instead of being
stuck in front of a page because when
we're stuck in front of a page or you
know by a page I mean like this and this
is how I interact with computers
and I kind of need to go there and I'm
stuck with this very linear
left-to-right paid shaped thing as long
as we're sitting at desks we think it's
gonna be harder to get to the ideas
where it's natural to have things
everywhere and be looking up and down
and so when we work for long hours we
don't want to be standing and running
around the way you might see in like VR
demos we mostly end up sitting on the
floor in various positions and and we
won't have all that space available so
this is kind of our floor office I'm
actually remote most of the team is out
here West and I'm in Boston and so we
have this kind of problem of trying to
bring our bodies together sometimes when
when when I can't fly over here every
day so I am also experimenting with just
programming as a VR a networked VR
office that we all visit together like
the one that she just showed and so I
focus more on the software part and it's
just a screenshot showing like two of
our avatars in a meeting and I also am
interested in what it might mean to
network art studios so working in an art
studio so much it is kind of a lonely
experience a lot but you know there's
this notion of needing other artists to
come and talk to you about your work and
see and and mess with things and mess
with your idea so that you can move your
work forward so in addition to our
networked office I'm also building a
network the art studio this is a
screenshot from a really recent
experiment I think I was these are cakes
again that I different more messy cakes
this time that I also 3d scanned and now
I'm gonna pivot a little bit to talk
about and what it means to what
experiences and what lessons I have
learned from China as I've been moving
my art studio practice to include more
VR and AR I showed you some of the VR
earlier I'm sorry
AR earlier but I also made myself of B
our art studio because I just got well
you know making art expensive and it's
hard to have infinite materials
especially if you're trying to make
physical things and VR kind of allows
you this freedom to make you know
objects that
free so back in any land I've been
playing a lot with the studio with this
time it's not ask and cake this is one
they just made out of like the 3d
primitives in any Landis cake
twice and I loved it because the moment
I made that I couldn't make all these
copies just immediately she's like oh
easy because that's the that's the
that's the impulse right the impulse to
have like fifty or more so I could do
that you know and then I could stack
them and make these sculptures and it
was just so easy no so fun so then
because I'm in VR I'm in anyway and I
could make an infinite studio and I
could just make as many as I want you
know and if as I'm walking down the
studio making these if I run out of
space I reach the edge of the studio I
just reach down and make the floor
bigger and have more studio that way or
more wall space so have a lot of fun in
there and it lets me start doing things
like make the cakes different colors you
know um play with monochrome which I'm
interested in I'm really interested in
making I think abstract imagery abstract
paintings at the end of the day so this
starts letting me start sketching kind
of some abstract imagery that has the
tonal qualities that I'm interested in
sometimes monochromatic sometimes not
the impulse to bring it back out into
the real world with physical objects I
think first thing I did is just laser
print since these you can take
screenshots in any land and so then I
laser print start getting some of that
nice texture back texture from the
printer texture from the paper you can
see more of the texture there I'm having
done too much more with that so when I
was making those and making them into
these 2d flat laser prints which are
interesting I have a wall full of them
but then again couldn't help but want to
see what it might feel like to have
those out in the world again in AR even
if they're digital and I had access to a
hololens and just rules i don't know
what hololens is a device from Microsoft
AR device from Microsoft you put it on
your head it's a clear screen you can
see through it and then Holograms appear
kind of in front of you on that little
screen they really need so we had a
couple on the team and I realized that I
could export as obj some of these things
I was making in any land and bring them
out into the war
so this is a hologram on a table in my
studio of one of those sculptures I had
made in any land these are those cake
slices all turned orange with like maybe
a rectangle and something else there and
I put it on a table in my studio the
hologram I had the headset on
but the hologram was about this big in
my studio and then I was like okay I
need to recreate it I just have to make
that into the real something real with
real materials and I just moved homes
and I didn't have much around except for
like sponges and a little bit of foam
and a hot glue gun and I just got to
work and the process this is kind of a
simulation the process felt something
like this this is the hologram sorry for
the low res and this is the sculpture I
started building next to it I was trying
to make it just look similar just
intuitively I could walk around it was
really fun this is me like I think I
carved a piece of soap and there's some
foam and stuff there and I was googling
where I could and then I got somewhere I
made something that kind you know and I
was so happy it was just like you know I
mean I lost myself in this process it
was so much fun it was just it was
something that felt like I was I was
taking you know when I work in VR in my
studio I think I feel like I have this
sensation that I'm somehow reaching into
my mind into my memories and then
rearranging things in there like I'm
reaching into my memories you know
finding some pretty difficult imagery
that that's hard to contend with but
then because I'm in VR and I have my
body I can I can contend with those
memories and move them around it's
really powerful for me and then extra
powerful is then taking it out as a
hologram on a table and then actually
you know turning into something tangible
kind of like giving birth to some
jumbled memories just another picture a
little clearer of a thing and at this
point you know this again was this
pretty small sculpture the next impulse
or I think next thing I really wanted to
be able to do was say bye like okay I
need a foam budget now we need a budget
we need lots of foam and lots of lots of
sponges I can make you know a hundred of
these but but we did not have a foam
budget so instead
oh there's just a couple more pictures
of the of the object from different
angles which again I could turn these
into paintings maybe or cover them in
plastic I'm not sure that's the hololens
in my studio with the hammer so because
I didn't have infinite foam yet but I
did have and this is in my new home my
new studio is this large barn space that
I hope to eventually turn into a VR AR
sculpture studio the first the next
thing I thought to do was you know what
well I've got the hololens I don't have
infinite foam but I do have infinite
pixels so why don't I maybe just try
making these things pretty large in my
studio so this is now just a fully
digital hologram one of those any land
cake things I just put it into the to
the barn see what it would feel like
this is probably a feet tall it's just
fun to see how that feels to have
something that's so large right in front
of you that came from your memories it's
kind of uh kind of the feeling I'm after
I think the sinking feeling in your
stomach um there's that same little guy
that I had the hologram that I reckon
replicated in sponges but now much
bigger and I can you know if you haven't
interacted with the hololens it's pretty
nice easy interface
um so I'm just rotating by pinching so
once I'm working large like this I
couldn't help but think like okay let me
go outside um why not and so I went you
know visited my husband's farm in
upstate New York and had all the space
and I just put the hololens on and
started just playing around when the
first things I do is like leave bread
crumbs around to see how how how how
good the tracking was and how far I
could go I went like half a mile and
still worked it was really fun um and
then I wanted to see what it would feel
like to make just you know but 20 foot
object in front of me these are all
virtual um since again I didn't have the
materials for it but I just made the
cylinder and put it in the landscape
I've never trained as an architect or
even as a sculptor I guess but it was
just so much fun to play play architect
first second and make make these kinds
of artworks that you know you put them
in the landscape somewhere and they do
something to you and so here's just like
a photo of one of those large large
cylinders that I put
um couple more photos i like suddenly
really understood this idea of
computation everywhere that you can just
have you know the power of computers at
your fingertips anywhere you want and
like I you know I knew that concept but
this is when it really clicked for me
was being like oh that's what it means
to have computation everywhere is
running across a field leaving
breadcrumbs in real time and and like
actually seeing that art work that that
was like a moment for me yeah thinking
about the programs that we were making
on the kitchen table in AR and I just
want to see what they would feel like
bigger you know it was like a larger
than life um computer program so this is
a program you know when you touch your
dog and this is a large dog she weighs
150 pounds so it's very big um so that's
you know what I mean to program kind of
at a macro scale and this is sort of
human scale but it also went one further
and just did a really quick experiment
with what are you present yeah really
quick experiment with there there for
loop from our VR programming language I
brought the for loop out into the farm
scape too and just made it extra large
this must have been like 25 30 feet tall
I just wanted to see what it would feel
like to walk through the for loop
through a forever loop
um I don't know I've never walked it
over a lever loop uh yeah where does
where does a for loop take you when you
walk through it and what's on the other
side
and yeah I'm gonna just wrap up I
suppose and that's that's all part of
this idea trying to get the body back
into computing so this is our workspace
this was our office in San Francisco
designed by ni Fleur of how to work in
space and office because when you're
stuck in front of this kind of flat
screen this desk metaphor paper metaphor
you're you're you're missing like how do
you actually live inside of your work in
a way that you can just have it
fundamental like intuitive in the sense
that you're doing it all the time you're
not designing this stuff from flat
you're working in it in an office where
you're sitting on the floor on cushions
crawling around and that's just your
everyday workspace and how how can you
program like that and how can you do art
like that how can you think and feel and
see in new ways okay thank you this
context right because like a lot of
programming is just like probably
pasting text and like gonna find replace
a workflow like getting stuff from Stack
Overflow talked about it but you didn't
quite show where she had the same
program written ten different ways which
were ten sculptures and I saw that as
different refactorings of the same thing
in a way but I guess I mean I don't want
to speak for you but I by my sense was
that so this is one of the refactorings
of that program she showed earlier and
if you were to turn this into a
different sculpture like what would your
process be I think is what he's asking
like maybe you'd shrink it yeah maybe
the interesting thing about when we had
this whole world of programs is that
suddenly it's really easy to find things
like if I want to find this
particular bit of code I know exactly
where it is because it has like a
sculptural identity and so when you're
talking about refactoring programs or
you have this whole mess of text and you
want to find and replace or even just
change the value of one variable right
now programs have very little texture
and you're kind of scrolling through
trying to find the right index for the
thing and it's horrible whereas here I
suddenly realize how horrible that way
is because it's so easy to just go in
the world and I know exactly where any
part of my program is so hopefully that
will help people be able to switch out
and in parts and change the design when
you can hold it all in your head in a
more spatial way yes yeah I was curious
about your use of metaphors well it
seems like a lot of what you do is
trying to like evaluate different
metaphors like what does this metaphor
mean how does it work it might reminded
me of like another lick upload the
metaphors we live by yes which is also I
mean reminded me a lot of like how do
you know when it's metaphor like you
I was curious like when you felt that
the metaphor was more successful or less
successful for example like one thing
that you're talking Miami it was like
what happens if program crashes now I
have to think of like what does the
creative you know space of like what
what a crash looks like mm-hmm
yeah and crash itself being a metaphor
yeah maybe like everything falls down
when it breaks apart or something right
when do you I guess how do you think
doing that yeah so we didn't show too
much of the Venn diagram project
although we've written about it a lot on
our website and that was something where
I started to feel like the metaphor was
working as an example so in this we had
different objects so we had this set of
kitchen drawers and and one of those
ideas in metaphors we live by or
philosophy in the flesh is that you know
the container of the drawer in your
kitchen teaches you what categories are
and how you categorize things and so I
made a set of drawers that was two
overlapping drawers and you could you
know open one or the other or both and
there's a space there was like a forked
drawer and a spoon drawer and if you
open both at once you got sport drive
exactly and so when I started really
immersing myself in making 50 Venn
diagrams and then he
more than 50 I just kind of Venn diagram
my heart out you know you start seeing
them everywhere because once you get
that in your body now like there was
more and more that I was seeing and
that's an example of I think a
successful metaphor where I think if
everyone could play with more overlaps
in their mind in their with their bodies
in VR where it's physically possible to
intersect things then we would also be
able to have more intersectionality at
the tip of our brain in real life
instead of it being kind of difficult to
think about and needing extra help to
think about when yes great wonderful
presentation I think it was extremely
inspiring I wonder if you you guys talk
to a lot of the presentation about
different visual programming techniques
or languages or styles and I wonder it
seems like so much of what you're
talking about really connects with kind
of programming by demonstration or at
least in terms of how you are showing
different emotions or different things
like that and I'm wondering if you could
talk at all about how you think what
parts of some of the languages that you
create and you think could be done by
demonstration verse some parts that it
seems like it would be hard to map that
to demonstration
Evelynn giving your experience and
demonstrating and helping people learn
scratch I think this is a good question
for you when you say when you say
programming by demonstrating you mean
would so for example in the key so
programming by demonstration is is one
technique of programming where you you
can essentially record yeah what you
want to do is not be able to play that
back and and so you know in the case of
where you have the the hand that points
to where something is touched and then a
bird comes out of that I could see that
being really directly mapped to like
someone being able to demonstrate oh I
touched this and then a bird comes out
of it and then that could be captured in
some representation but then some of
your other kind of more of procedurally
oriented things might be harder
do and so I was wondering if if you
thought at all about connecting sort of
the motion that you were trying to show
in terms of the earlier work that you
showed in terms of you know showing
acceleration and other things in terms
and then connecting that with the
directness of the programming something
that makes me think of a some work we
didn't show by M that having to do with
scales of abstraction in interfaces
which maybe was getting a little bit
what you're asking but yeah what you're
asking could be a whole talk I think
about programming language design and to
answer that first I guess I would just
say we haven't played enough and I was I
think I was waiting for us to just get
all the different parts out there and
then think about how to connect them and
that's probably where we would move next
is to think about what you're thinking
what you're saying but then M has done
some work sort of along those lines
where I think I could connect into the
programming stuff in VR M has designed
which what they're calling um different
scales of interface meaning they made a
podcast app in VR and they have three
different scales for it one is wearable
so it's it's it's in my ear I'm wearing
it the podcast app I'm wearing it if I
want to play it play it I just touched
my ear that's one scale it's the
wearable scale the next one is holdable
and I just take off my earring podcast
app and I'm holding it kind of inflates
a little bit and I see more detail and
then I can interact with it a little
more I can I can rearrange the playlist
or I can move things around and then the
next scale is to press maybe something
in the holdable one and it inflates even
more into the size of a room and now I'm
walking through my podcast app and I can
feel I can see it I can see more detail
and the programming by demonstration
stuff and how it relates to kind of the
more the other kind of programming I
think could could benefit from a similar
kind of scale shift or kind of you know
like um you have someone come in and say
yeah I won I want that when the bottle
Falls like this it makes a splash sound
and that's my demonstration and then to
go in there
maybe I click on something in the
interface and then I'm at the level of
the code and there's a
another embodied way to think about the
coding so I don't know if that makes it
does that I'm just really so Ken purlins
work at NYU actually is also a chalk
talk is kind of this programming ish
language I don't know what you would
actually call it but that does have some
okay the world of animation is often in
animation there's things were like oh I
want to just show the animation software
what passed the thing takes by drawing
the pass and then it will animate along
the path so yeah the most relevant work
to VR and programming I think is Ken's
work that kind of takes some of those
animation techniques into programming
languages using drawing and some there's
some of that some aspects of that so
yeah we'd love to bring more of that in
[Applause]
you